my name is Devon Brewer and I'm going to
talk about strategies for successful
grant proposals
because I will give advice about how to
write grant proposals let me tell you a
little about a little bit about my
background I have over 25 years of
experience in writing successful grant
proposals in the Health Sciences
I have been a principal investigator on
several grants and a key contributor to
many others I have written funded
proposals or reviewed proposals for the
National Institutes of Health the
National Science Foundation the Centers
for Disease Control and Prevention and
the health resources and Services
Administration the Medical Research
Council private foundations and other
agencies
as a scientific adviser and writer with
science stocks I help researchers
develop and compose effective proposals
and manuscripts
in this tour of writing grant proposals
I'll start with what I think is an
essential mindset for the whole
enterprise this mindset leads to
specific actions to ensure the content
and presentation of a proposal matches a
grant opportunity
then I'll highlight some logistic and
bureaucratic matters to address for an
effective submission I'll close with
some suggestions about how to build
skill and developing and writing grant
proposals and where you can get feedback
on in help in preparing proposals
although most of the examples I give
relate to funding funding agencies in
the United States the strategies I
discussed are you likely to be useful in
other countries as well
to have an effective mindset for writing
a successful grant proposal it helps to
understand two basic facts of the
research grant game
the first is that thunders give grants
to advance their missions which usually
are of a practical political economic or
ideological nature
a project that is not aligned with the
funders agenda will not get funded no
matter how excellent important or
creative the science is
the second basic fact is that scientists
who apply for research grants and
contracts therefore our vendors offering
research projects for sale
so a research grant is not a handout
just to advance your career or satisfy
your curiosity although you might be
able to achieve these while benefiting
your funder
you are selling your research it pays to
follow the first rule of sales no your
customer but who are your customers
they are the review panel and funding
agency officials
the review panel is an intermediary and
you have to make your offer appeal to
their agendas - they will try to a
certain extent to adhere to agency
priorities and views but they will also
have their own that they seek to apply
with reviewing proposals
and reviewers may vary in their
individual agendas as well
you
there are several strategies you can use
to know your customers with respect to
the content of your proposed research
usually you have an idea for a research
project and want to seek funding for it
in this case the first step is to search
for potential funders consider all types
of possible sponsors including
government agencies private foundations
industrial corporations patient advocacy
groups and other nonprofit organizations
grants.gov has a directory to all
federal funding agencies I've given the
link here
search the web intensively for non
government funders
identified a potential thunder pick the
most relevant grant opportunities or
programs
I've given the links to listings for the
National Institutes of Health and the
National Science Foundation examine the
alternatives thoroughly look for good
fits in terms of topic and size of
project
if you don't have an idea to begin with
reviewing funding opportunity
announcements or fos may spark an idea
if you already had an idea you may
decide to modify it in light of these
announcements
next identify the specific target for
your proposal within the funding agency
study previous grants made by the
program or programs in which you're
interested
I've given links to the relevant
databases for the National Institutes of
Health in the National Science
Foundation
if you plan to submit the National
Institutes of Health also examine the
emphases and rosters of the review
panels called study sections
search for publications by the reviewers
and visit their web pages to understand
their specialties and inclinations
these sources of information will help
you decide precisely which program fo a
and review panel is best for your
project
try to find the program and review panel
that is most similar to your idea in
substitute methodological and
theoretical terms avoid programs and
review panels that are likely to be
hostile to or unfamiliar with your
approach and perspective
once you have identified your target
program in fo a or are still uncertain
email and then call the program officer
to discuss your idea the program officer
may give you a sense of the program's
current priorities and the tendencies of
the review panel this is as close as you
can get to communicating with your
ultimate customer take seriously what
the program officer tells you
all this you may want to revise your
idea further based on what you have
learned
in the proposal itself make sure you
highlight how your project will address
one or more topics listed in the FO a if
they were specified as you write take
the agency's perspective show how your
work connects to the funders priorities
and goals don't propose research to a
government agency that is difficult or
impossible to fund for political reasons
don't propose research to other funders
that is it odds with their ideologies
try to make your proposal seem like it
is within the same stream of research as
that of the reviewers and recent
grantees
reviewers can be very tribal and they
want to feel like they are supporting
one of their own
integrate your proposed project with
their work and sighted
early revolutionary ideas are not
fundable most scientists will not break
entirely with convention or current
understanding without evidence and a
proposal is merely a plan to gather
evidence
individual scientists can take such
risks on their own but funders generally
do not you still can come you still can
propose something new or different as
long as it doesn't challenge
foundational beliefs
reviewers and funders want to support
successful projects so include any
preliminary data and results you have
related to your proposed research to
demonstrate the viability and potential
outcomes for your project
proposal is a sales document maintain
scientific integrity throughout describe
prior work fairly give others credit
where it is due ensure all claims have a
factual basis and avoid hyperbole
include best practices such as
pre-registration of study protocols and
public archiving of data in your plans
acknowledged limitations and state how
you will address them or why the project
is valuable despite them
the content of other sections beyond the
main text are important too unless the
grant is small or for new investigators
at least one of the main investigators
on the project should have considerable
research experience in the area of the
proposal a track record
typically demonstrated by relevant
publications is crucial for all key
researchers on the project
show that you are ready to begin the
project identify by name if possible who
will fill each major role rather than
indicating the person is to beat to be
determined exclude individuals with
nominal involvement for tiny percentages
of time unless they feel very specific
and limited technical roles
budgets are often scrutinized by
reviewers and funders alike regardless
of the detail required in the proposal
over estimation of a budget can be a
sign of inexperience or attempted abuse
of grant funds
underestimation of a budget can also be
a sign of inexperience and ignorance
the Thunder requires a description of
specific costs justify exactly how they
are necessary for the project and the
project alone
many funders cut grantees budgets after
awarding their grants for reasons
unrelated to those specific projects so
be ready with a back-up plan of how you
would achieve your project goals with
for example a 10 percent or 25 percent
cut tier budget
knowing your customer also applies to
how you present your proposed project
if you do not prepare your proposal well
it has no chance at funding no matter
how good your content is
how well you prepare the proposal
reflects your attention to detail
ability to adhere to procedures and
communication skills which are all
essential for carrying out a successful
research project therefore follow all
application instructions exactly
consider your reviewers constantly as
you write and design your proposal few
reviewers will be expert on your
specific topic and many might even be
from entirely different fields sometimes
only one or two reviewers give comments
on a proposal so chance may figure
promise prominently and who will review
your proposal
remember that reviewers are tired and
overworked volunteers in a rush
these circumstances have several
implications for how you will compose
your proposal
because you cannot know the extent of
the reviewers knowledge explain your
assumptions and all specialized concepts
techniques theories and terms
the project summary or abstract in the
specific game section in National
Institutes of Health proposals are the
most important parts of the proposal
text these are the only parts some
reviewers will read and full as they
skim the rest for all reviewers these
parts set the tone
good first impressions can be lost that
bad first impressions are very difficult
to overcome
all scientific writing brevity is
critical reviewers have other proposals
to read and unnecessary words and
material hurt your case
organize and format your proposal in
simple clear and consistent ways the
reviewers can navigate and find
information easily avoid using text
effects such as bolding and underlining
within paragraphs
these effects imply some words and
sentences are more important than others
which readers can interpret his meaning
the others can be skipped
considerable planning and coordination
with administrators are required to
produce a successful proposal expect to
spend at least several months developing
and preparing all aspects of your
proposal writing a grant proposal is not
like writing a research article it is
more like writing two or three long
research articles in terms of time and
effort involved
we humans especially scientists writing
grant proposals are chronic under
estimators of the time needed to
accomplish tasks remember Hofstadter's
law it always takes longer than you
expect even when you take into account
Hofstadter's law
schedule for when you and others will do
different tasks for the proposal
building extra cushions of time and hard
deadlines stick to the schedule
if you fall too far behind be prepared
to postpone submission to a later grant
cycle or another opportunity
once you have identified the funder and
grant opportunity you will seek make
sure you are eligible to serve as
principal investigator and that your
organization is eligible to receive the
grant
check that the grant duration and
overall cost allowed fits with your
project ideas
if your organization is new to seeking
research grants especially from
government funders there may be various
registrations and accounts that your
administrators will need to establish
also your proposal schedule should
include all relevant deadlines set by
the funder
the administrative aspect of a proposal
is just as important as a scientific
aspect once you decide to develop a
proposal meet with administrators at
your organization
figure out who will be responsible for
each component of the proposal and every
task related to it identify internal
deadlines
incorporate the division of labor and
these internal deadlines into your
proposal development schedule
good relationships with administrative
staff are crucial for preparing a
successful proposal if possible be
concise and guidance from experienced
grant administrators they can help you
avoid bureaucratic problems both with
the Thunder and your own organization
prioritize getting the necessary
approvals from your organization's
biosafety Animal Care or Human Subjects
committees you may need to revise your
planned project and go through multiple
committee meeting cycles before your
proposal is approved
the best way to learn how to write
successful grant proposals is to
apprentice with experienced writers of
successful grant proposals
if this is not possible for you then
volunteer to proofread a review or
proposal by a colleague who has received
grants before
another option is to ask colleagues
whether you can study successful grant
proposals that they've written
in a grant proposal you are not only
selling a research project you are also
selling yourself you stand a better
chance at funding if you are a known
contributor to the field
therefore presented conferences publish
your work and agree to review
manuscripts in your field before you
develop a proposal if possible
reviewers and funders are putting their
trust in you just as much as they are
your idea and plan
getting feedback on
proposal maybe even more important than
getting feedback on a manuscript because
a proposal is a plan that still can
change while a manuscript is a report of
something that already happened
at a minimum have all key scientific
personnel proofread and review the whole
proposal ask other colleagues to review
the proposal as well and seek their
feedback on your ideas even before you
begin writing
there are also other resources you can
draw on at science stocks we help
researchers and all phases of developing
and writing grant proposals and
manuscripts we have experts in every
specialty ready to assist you can learn
more at science.com
thank you for your attention